Chris my dear I love it I love it I love
it
I hope you're loving it too man just
just won't give you guys a great big
season's greetings happy holiday that of
course Merry Merry Christmas so excited
always love this day and I have a
certain something to share with you a
little Christmas message that means a
lot to me hopefully means a lot to you
as some of you may or may not know I
lost my mother this year and I was
totally out of the blue as peacefully in
her sleep but I mean it just came out of
nowhere and took us all by surprise and
I'm not sure a little something with you
that I think you'll take the heart at
least something that she always used to
tell me because she she loved my stuff
she loved what I did but this is a proud
Catholic woman and she'd always say I
love your stuff but why do you have to
use such bad language why do you have to
do that and years and years you would
always say it is as you say all I reason
was Walt Disney I reason into church on
everything she'd only think why do you
have to use the f-word why do you use
all the four-letter words and what I
usually bring up is I'd say well how
about that scene in Blues Brothers where
the nun is slapping them for swearing
and you go okay that's the one time it's
funny and I said well how about that
time in Pulp Fiction when Huma Thurman
was OD'ing and there's raining up those
storms you know okay that's two twice as
funny away well there can be two times
there can be other time then should go
back to right now it's not funny and
it's offensive and blah blah blah so
something I would do is because this is
something I didn't see coming when I was
doing this is that people would start
sending me emails saying that I've
helped them through stuff just by having
something certain in their lives
something funny something positive that
they can constantly go to every week
it's like that little bit of stability
in an unstable world that you know or
unstable environments and people can be
and so I would take those every year and
I would put them in a little collection
called they all like the f-word and
these are the emails that people sent
over a course
of a year and I would have put them
together I print them out and I would
give them to my mother as you can see
this would be the sixth edition this
will have been the six year that we've
given it to her and all the names by the
way our our blot out don't worry I mean
nobody's identities given away but the
stories are still there word for word
and I guess the big thing about is that
you know she would see this and she
would appreciate it I mean this is one
of those people you saw in that worth
Christmas special ever video her at the
end where she loved to help people she
was a big helper and she loved spreading
the idea of just making people feel
better make you feel better
kind of thing and you know you sort of
take you need to sing yourself but you
know you sort take yourself out of the
equation sometimes too and what really
surprised both of us when this whole
thing started and just kept going and
going and going below nostalgia critic
thing is that you know this was not the
original intention it was definitely to
spread laughs and have fun and
everything but we weren't thinking like
oh wow like helping people because
there's stuff where people talk about
you know I was suicidal I lost somebody
recently I was in war and just watching
your stuff can you know really help and
I guess what I'm trying to get across
with this is that it works both ways in
terms of the whole giving and receiving
thing and around the holidays everyone
always says always not about the
receiving it's about you know the giving
and that's true but it is also learning
how to receive that love too it's about
giving love but it is also about
receiving love and not all of us are
great at that
sometimes when we're given a compliment
we say out no it's not that's not a
immediately deny you like we're
uncomfortable accepting something nice
and I think Christmas is definitely a
time not just giving something nice but
accepting something nice that you can be
accepting not only of others but you can
be accepting of yourself and I think
this kind of stuff and these kind of
stories kind of show that there are
people that are having a hard time
accepting themselves and
that I kind of feel like when when
they're going through that they do look
for something no matter how strange or
weird or whatever that can help them out
and a lot of people in here say oh you
really helped me you've changed my life
or something like that
and I want to say to all of you you have
changed my life and that's why me when I
say it works both ways because so many
celebrities always say all wiII be
nowhere without you and you think oh
well they they have to say that well one
you're right two they don't always
because uh you know there are some
celebrities and people that go through
stuff that where they can't see it or
they can't feel it and that is a shame
but there's definitely a large amount
that do realize how important you are
and how important the people that watch
and share and talk about such positive
things how important they really are so
when people like us say it really is all
from you guys and it's so wonderful and
you really are the world I can
definitely say I really mean and I know
a lot of people who mean it as well so
you know you can look at this stuff and
you can be like oh you've really helped
me through so much stuff you know you
changed my life you really have changed
my life you have made so much of my
happiness possible and you know if just
making these silly videos I can make you
happy as well it really is the least I
can do because you guys really do help
share so much of that love and so much
of what Christmas is just not around
Christmas but year-round and it really
really means the world I know that's
what my mother always tried to get done
try to spread that love and you know the
idea of sharing and being kind and just
how powerful it is to help others and
how much it comes back and it really
does reward you um so it's but it's all
in different ways it is in such
different ways and I think that's one of
the reasons I made this is because she
said well that f-word can't you know
nobody can like that nobody can get into
it like you know just people people at
different languages they have different
cultures and
time I would make this for her she would
see then she would read these stories a
lot of times she read one before going
to bed your even email and I really
wanted to say that you know you guys
help with that you guys
you constantly help people like me and
my mom see various ways to help and
different cultures different languages
just all sorts of variety and that is so
phenomenal and I am just so thankful to
have you guys in my life and it just
means the world to me and this would
have done year six and it drives me nuts
that I can't I can't give this tour but
you can see I had it made anyway and who
knows maybe maybe she is seeing anything
it you know we all know what happens
after this world but you know it's one
of those things where I made it anyway
not just for her but for you guys
because it really really I really mean a
while you say you mean the world it just
you have changed my life you mean so
much and I know I'm just I repeat right
now but I love saying it I love saying
how much you guys have just affected my
life so thank you all so much and just
remember the things you never would have
thought of you never would have thought
of that like you know just going around
cursing and talking about movies could
help people through stuff you know but
anyway this is a sixth edition of this
and it's those good those good ideas and
that bit of kindness works in ways that
you're not even aware of
so do it anyway do it even if you think
it's not working because majority of
time it is you're just not aware of and
find different ways to do it find ways
that maybe nobody thought about there's
so much kindness and so much positivity
that can be shared and there's so many
various ways to do it
so um everybody have a phenomenal
Christmas keep it in your heart today
keeping it heart tomorrow keeping your
hearts a whole year out as much as you
can you're still human like me you're
going to make mistakes and we're all
going to have goof-ups but just try your
best man you know because that effort
goes a long way and that trying goes so
far so thank you all so much and have a
wonderful wonderful Christmas sticker